what the tradcons will often say is well
it'll take so much time to change the
laws in the meantime you should just get
married well my question is why would
the institutions change if they keep
having willing customers that sign up so
Ben says marriage will make you a better
person I would argue that is very
dependent on the man and the wife there
are absolutely nagging belittling wives
that make marriage a living hellhole for
men and no it does not make them a happy
healthier person Ben says you should
Date with an eye towards marriage
seeking a commonality of values the
single most important foundation for a
lasting marriage Ben is really selling
here that if you just find a woman with
a commonality of values that it is not
the risks that it that it is not as
risky as the Pearl doom and gloomer will
say